[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiero contarles qué
empezar contándoles que cuando era un
muchacho de unos diez años hubo una
anécdota de mi padre que marcó gran
parte de mi vida
y se trata de una reunión en aquel
estuvo con periodistas amigos y mucha
gente llena que estaba también el
general guillermo rodríguez lara en ese
entonces el dictador del ecuador
entonces mi papá estaba que contaba
chistes y más chistes sobre militares
pues la gente se moría de risa hasta que
llegó alguien por detrás y le dice con
sado se te está yendo la mano aunque te
pasa si a él si le gusta general no es
cierto que usted no le disgusta que le
cuenten chistes de militares así es
licenciado ya veces ya ves si él se
enoja es cuando se los explican entonces
y yo escuchaba tras la pared de estas
anécdotas que le festejaban los amigos y
para mí fue una anécdota maravillosa
porque me indicó el camino de que el
humor puede ser una herramienta o una
manera de expresar y plantarte frente a
un personaje poderoso a un dictador a un
presidente a un vanidoso etcétera
realmente yo a él le debo todo
más la biblioteca por supuesto que me
alejo de los libros ahí en la foto
ustedes pueden ver es cuando lo tomaron
preso y gracias a él aumentó por el
camino del humor y del humor gráfico que
lo ejerzo ya desde hace más de 30 años
en mi país de ecuador en donde por
cierto los últimos 10 años anteriores
estuvo presidido por el economista
rafael correa quien se caracterizó por
una persecución tenaz a la prensa y por
acallar a todo el que pensara distinto o
lo cuestionara o lo criticara
para contextualizar les estoy hablando
de un presidente que puso una demanda
por 80 millones de dólares a un
periódico por un artículo de opinión que
según él afectaba su honra un presidente
que puso un juicio por 10 millones de
dólares a dos periodistas de
investigación como pueden ser quizá
muchos de los que están aquí aunque en
el futuro lo serán por haber publicado
un libro de investigación en donde se
demostraba que el presidente conocía los
contratos que el hermano de él tenía con
el estado
hablamos de un presidente que en sus
programas sabatinos rompía periódicos
y que incluso cuando iba en la caravana
presidencial él personalmente descendía
del auto para atrapar a algún ciudadano
que hubiera osado criticado criticarlo
o insultarle o hacerle un gesto obsceno
como sucedió por ejemplo con este chico
de 16 años que que fue en cuerpo
literalmente por el presidente e hizo
que lo tomaran lo tomarán presos bueno
en este contexto del país que yo les
estoy contando me sucedió a mí algo y es
que una ocasión me llama un amigo y me
dice javier prende la televisión este
rato urgente porque no aprenden
lo hice y lo primero que yo veo es al
presidente que decía
cobarde mentiroso enfermo corrupto yo al
comienzo pensé que les estaba tomando
lista ahí
hasta que puse atención y me di cuenta
que todos esos insultos me los decía a
mí por qué
bueno estaba furioso porque yo había
publicado
una caricatura sobre el allanamiento al
periodista fernando villavicencio en el
que yo daba cuenta de cómo había
sucedido aquello y que se habían llevado
además los dispositivos electrónicos que
contenían las denuncias y la información
de corrupción del gobierno que hoy al
pasar de los años se ha demostrado que
eran reales gracias a las relaciones de
odebrecht
entonces está descargó toda la furia
dijo que iban a aplicar todas a la
fuerza de la ley y el gracias a una ley
de comunicación que ellos inventaron y
cuando me llegó la notificación yo me
quedé helado porque no podía creer que a
mí me estuviera sucediendo algo que yo
había leído que sucedía en otros países
donde realmente se persigue al humor
bueno fue
una época muy tensa y yo me acuerdo que
mi esposa y una mañana me dice mi amor
sí aunque no quedan a veces me dice así
es mi amor tal vez no será de que
dibujes de otro modo no sé de ella no de
política que hagas otras cosas entonces
yo me resentí
elige pues decir eso lo que necesito es
que me apoyes ella se puso a llorar yo
la abracé los dos lloramos y claro
estábamos asustados
por qué
un presidente con toda esa fuerza con
todo ese poder resulta que además de
insultarme nos estaba persiguiendo
yo tenía ahí algunas opciones o sea
podía haberme echado a llorar podía
haberme escondido a que mi abogado sea
quien me defendiera
podía haber gritado y salir a la calle
enfurecido a descargar mi rabia pero en
lugar de eso decidí ir a una tienda una
papelería me compré una enorme plancha
de cartón fui a mi casa con lo que sobre
la mesa del comedor tras el diseño y
empecé a cortar cuando llegó gabriel a
la hija de mi esposa me dice que está
haciendo javier llegó un lápiz un lápiz
y un lápiz puede ser un lápiz y voy a
hacer otro que es un lápiz enorme que
básicamente es un borrador porque eso es
lo que ellos quieren borrar nuestra
opinión borrar nuestra nuestro
pensamiento y entonces
decidí sin agresividad y sin temor
también asistir a la superintendencia
aquella vez llevando mis dos lápices y
que por cierto no sabían si dejarme
entrar o no hasta que yo voy a hacer que
les des accionado dejen entrar
logré entrar y levantando el uno dije
este es el lápiz que queremos los
caricaturistas y periodistas y este
mostrando el que es básicamente un
borrador este es el que quieren los
sensores y el gobierno bueno les dice
dibujitos explicando que una caricatura
es un proceso de construcción de una
opinión no una bomba que les va a
desestabilizar un gobierno pero ellos no
les convenció mi inocencia ni mi candor
y finalmente nos sancionaron
a mí me obligaron a que rectificara el
dibujo y ya el diario el universo a que
pague
más de 90 mil dólares por una caricatura
yo obedecí la orden y entonces dice la
rectificación
que fue una gran risotada en el país
porque yo dibujé a la policía llegando a
la casa de la llanada con flores
ofreciendo disculpas y el afectado el
allanado los recibía contara la alegría
y la confianza de que por fin lleguen
las autoridades a allanarle y llevarse
en sus equipos y bueno el presidente
estaba furioso
el presidente estaba furioso dijo esto
no es una rectificación esto es una
tomadura de pelo que quien se cree este
sujeto que no representa a nadie y llegó
al extremo de retarme a que nos miramos
en las urnas
que si yo me lanzaba al candidato de
algo no sacaban y dos votos
quienes tenía razón porque justo estaba
peleado yo de mi mujer entonces nombras
bueno el caso es que siguió acosando e
incluso vía twitter se pronunciaba y un
año después encontró otra oportunidad en
donde me acusó de haber cometido el
delito penal de racismo un delito que se
castiga con tres años incluso de tres
años de prisión
incitó a la gente a que me denunciara y
efectivamente unos colectivos afro me
denunciaron en la superintendencia por
haber hecho este meme de aquí en donde
yo cuestionaba el desempeño de un
asambleísta de su partido de gobierno
que da la casualidad que es un
exfutbolista
a quien se le veía en un vídeo leyendo
como un chico de primer grado y que
además era un afrodescendiente detalle
que para mí es absolutamente irrelevante
el color de la piel pero que el
presidente aprovechó y encontró una
ocasión propicia para acusarme de
racismo entonces tuve que construir me
unos lentes gigantes con los que acudir
a la superintendencia para regalarles a
las autoridades que se hacían de la
vista gorda de los insultos y del
comportamiento ese sí discriminatorio
del presidente cuando a muchos
ciudadanos les llamaba enano enfermo o
algunos medios de comunicación no les
entregaba información simplemente porque
eran medios privados
bueno el caso es que nos sancionaron y
nos obligaron a ponernos de rodillas ya
pedir disculpas o ofrecer disculpas yo
les pregunto una cosa
si ustedes fueran presidentes del país o
presidenta no se aburrirían de estar
peleando con caricaturistas
me imagino que sí pero correa no
entonces continuamos tirándome incluso
llegó a un extremo de una sabatina
mostró mi foto lo cual ya me perjudicaba
mostró mi foto y señalando señalando me
dijo jóvenes cuando lo veo en la calle
hacer quien sea reclamarlo
por supuesto que hubo gente que me
ofrecía su apoyo pero otros
yo hice este dibujo que era mi manera de
ridiculizarlo y lo puse en twitter
pero hubo gente que sí me ofreció su
apoyo y asimismo u otros que me
ofrecieron dar una paliza felizmente
cuando yo ya veía el perfil de este
twitter o ya me tranquilizaba porque
resulta que era muy creyente en cristo
bueno
la verdad es que ya ha pasado algún
tiempo y debo confesarles algo y es que
para mí ha sido muy difícil mirarme
evaluarme aunque hay mucha gente que me
dice que el modo como yo reaccioné
como que rompió un dique
y efectivamente así fue y en artículos
de prensa en las redes sociales en
comentarios familiares se escuchaba
se perdió el miedo
y efectivamente así fue porque
normalmente cuando uno se enfrenta a un
grandulón abusivo uno tiende a hincharse
no a engrandecer te para poder
enfrentarte el humor hace lo contrario
el humor no no se engrandece sino que le
vuelve pequeño al contrincante
le vuelve enano el grandulón y de ese
modo lo vuelve más manejable
entonces es algo así como como el triple
de messi ante dos defensas corpulentos y
metegol
el agresivo qué es lo que quiere el
agresivo quiere que te enojes
quiere mostrar su musculatura y medirse
con la tuya
quiere que le tengas miedo
y entonces cuando respondes con humor
relativiza de esa peligrosidad no haces
caso aunque exista el peligro te burlas
de la de la bravuconada y de ese modo
neutralizar
por cierto yo me acuerdo de alguna
manera es como una valentía no y por eso
yo me acuerdo que caminaba en esa época
por la calle y alguien me grita me dice
bonil yo regrese a ver y me dice
valiente que le conocerán a mi mujer
bueno no le conocía pero
y entonces es que el humor en realidad
es una en mi caso fue así una un triunfo
imaginario
cierto es que no logramos parar las
multas ni las amonestaciones pero fue
una victoria simbólica
porque demostramos
y no nos doblegamos y que no le teníamos
miedo
y qué es lo que quiere un abusador un
agresor
que le temas
y el humor es precisamente lo que lo que
permite evitar el miedo evitar el dolor
sortear a mí personalmente me sirvió
para sortear ese periodo para poder
responder y así flaquito como soy poder
surfear la agresividad
que venía
y entonces a mí me ha servido para
aprender a responder con un poco más de
tolerancia de serenidad en las redes
sociales por ejemplo si alguien insulta
yo no hago caso sí que pueden insultarme
cuando quieran
hubo alguien que cuando si es que
alguien
yo estoy conduciendo mi auto si alguien
me insultan me agrede yo no saco la
cabeza y le respondo
de eso se encarga mi mujer que es un
buenísimo verte
pero una vez hubo alguien en facebook
que me dijo que me amenazó que te voy a
desfigurar la cara cuando te vea
yo le respondí ahórrate el trabajo y ya
está muy dañada
en definitiva el humor es de eso y
mencionó el caso de las redes sociales
que puede sonar muy trivial pero que es
un desafío cotidiano en donde nosotros
podemos expresar la tolerancia expresar
el humor
porque tenemos todos batallas que lidiar
socialmente individualmente
familiarmente puedo decirles como
resumen quizás que a mí el humor si me
sirvió para surfear y me sirvió en
segundo lugar para defender algo que es
muy importante
la libertad de expresión
para concluir lo que les podría decir
quisiera decirles de ese entonces
hagan el humor todos los días
embarazo de una sonrisa al mundo pero
háganlo con la luz encendida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]